know yeah do you think you could
love a man unconditionally no
yeah i think if i'm being honest no
why do you say no no because if he
murdered somebody i would leave sas okay
yeah like i'd be out
oh no if you had bundied me oh no
that's a condition that's good point
do you do you think men can love women
unconditionally
um
i i think
more so than women can but i do think
that if a girl was 500 pounds
the guy would be less attached to her he
would be less attached but sexually yeah
yeah romantically yeah well you see all
these podcasts recently though like if
my wife gains weight like when she's
pregnant all that stuff but but men
don't leave yeah they don't most of them
stay and so i saw a thing recently like
and this comes back to
the like research that i did when i did
like my degree and it was like um
women again quality over quantity but
men will actually
tend to get to a point where they're
like oh [ __ ] i actually need to settle
down and actually so they actually won't
they will men will actually settle which
is a really unpopular opinion yeah
because they'll get to a point where
they're like oh [ __ ] you know what i've
been seeing it done it all everyone else
is settling down she'll do she works
with what i want do you think men settle
because they're more realistic and women
are unrealistic
so like like women we kind of lie to
each other well massive romantic as well
well and we and we lie to each other
like we'll say lizzo is hot when come on
like
you're laughing because you know exactly
what i'm saying i know yeah i know right
like you you get more attention because
you're you're thin right oh 100 yeah
yeah pretty privileged is a real thing
the halo effect is a real thing right
right there's a reason i dressed up for
tonight there's a reason for some reason
yeah and which is which is all good and
well but like will we tell our friend
that
no no
you try and be a good person you're
trying to be supportive but
like the the facts speak for themselves
the psychology speaks for itself like
yeah yeah are less attracted to a big
unless they've got like a kink for it
men let's attract to a bigger woman but
i think like we almost like lie to girls
and say don't settle don't settle but
like you have to settle on something
like yeah like you gotta i mean if
you're not perfect you can't expect the
person you date
i i
i don't believe
that there's such a thing as settling
and what i mean is this
like as human beings we're quite
selfish we always choose what we feel is
the best option yeah
so if you choose someone
right
that was the best option you have
because that's not you settling that's
like saying oh i settled to go to
reading university instead of going to
oxford it's like well you didn't get an
offer from oxford so you're not settling
for reading you just didn't get you
didn't have the option that you wanted
so like i don't believe there's actually
a thing called setting because it sounds
like the people that went to a d3 school